[Music]
you were on the cover of Cosmo which has
got to be kind of cool but then I notice
that they put its a very nice picture of
you but they put all of these headlines
around you that don't have anything to
do with you but it's kind of upsetting
it's time he wants you mode but you know
you read from left to right and so my
dad sees this and we all see this and he
thinks that best sex ever is what I
talked about in my interview and so I
was like daddy
I promise if you look to the right it
will clearly say like my name but I
think things got a little misconstrued
my dad was a little he sent me a text
message it was like you look great but
the head titles are a little oh he
actually said that to you did I think I
gave you I think we have your text right
here oh it's just on your pick I'm not
too crazy about the articles beside your
photo love you thanks daddy
oh that's three hearts he knows how to
use his emojis my father never sent me
three hard yeah and I bet your dad still
doesn't know when sex o'clock is he does
not know when sex o'clock is
you